[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL MURPHY: We started
Dots two years ago.
And my co-founder
Patrick had this idea
to create an art-inspired game,
a game that we wanted to play.
My name is Paul Murphy.
I'm one of the co-founders
of Dots, and I'm the CEO.
We launched Dots and we
had a lot of downloads.
Millions of people
started playing this game.
It was a little bit
overwhelming and we
had a lot of feature requests.
BEN RUDLIN: My
name's Ben Rudlin.
I'm the visual designer
on TwoDots at Dots.
One of the hardest
challenges has
been trying to find that sweet
spot between functionality
and fun.
But at the same time
from the UI perspective,
there's certain
communication that
has to be conveyed, so people
know what they're doing.
CHRISTIAN CALDERON: My
name is Christian Calderon,
the head of marketing at Dots.
Early on, some of the
qualitative measures
that we would look
at in the game
was just how people would
react to holding the phone
and connecting dots.
The challenge with
that is it's not
scalable to do that over
70 different countries
with millions and
millions of players.
TONY HE: My name's Tony He.
I'm a data scientist at Dots.
Google Play Experiments is
kind of a one-stop service
which enabled us to upload
different marketing assets.
BEN RUDLIN: Icons, screenshots,
copy that goes with those,
and optimize the directions
that we go with those.
CHRISTIAN CALDERON: Google
Play Store Experiments
have helped us in two main ways.
One is it had an impact on
helping us really understand
how changes that we make
impact user behaviour.
Our control, the icon that
we had currently in the game,
had a white background,
and we tested that
with another icon that
had a black background.
And what we realized
was that the icon
with the white background
just performed a lot better.
The second is just the
impact of the business.
We've tested many different
things with out screenshots.
The two largest ones
were illustrating
gameplay graphically.
Also, illustrating
gameplay with text.
And what we noticed
was that together, they
had a compound effect, a
positive effect on conversion
of about 8% when used localized.
The experiments help us
become smarter at what we do.
It also has a business impact.
TONY HE: It is very easy to use.
You don't need to implement
those analytical tracking.
You don't need to worry
about segmentation.
All of those things will
be done automatically.
CHRISTIAN CALDERON: The advice
I'd give to other developers
is to always seek knowledge.
Never stop trying
to learn new things.
BEN RUDLIN: Don't be
afraid to make mistakes,
and to learn from them.
PAUL MURPHY: Our
plan with Dots is
to continue making
Dots-based games.
We've created a
mechanic that we think
is unique, very creative-led.
We find the creativity,
we find the fun,
and then we try to layer on the
business aspects afterwards.
[MUSIC PLAYING]